hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from the final round of
the very strong tournament the I
referred open 2019 this is a game from
the 8th tournament which means you have
to be at least 20 550 in a low rating to
apply it's a game between two very
strong Armenian Grandmaster Steiger and
Ivanovich petrosyan and hike Martirosyan
Martirosyan is only 18 years also for
but he already won the World Youth
Championship in 2016 and in the in 2018
he won the Armenian Chess Championship
and the Tigran Petrosian also won the
Armenian championship two times already
so a very exciting game and I do hope
you'll enjoy it like I said the arrow
fold open lasts from 19 to 27th of
February and the prize fund well not the
prize fund but the first prize for
winning the tournament is 18 18 thousand
euros so that's a lot of money of course
it you know brought a lot of very strong
grandmasters to the tournament and I
don't think yes Martha Rosen is playing
for dove for the first prize but as
there is one more game going while I'm
recording this video I don't know if it
will be known before that game ends so
you have to check that after we check
out this video I'm okay saying that the
tournament is being held in the cosmos
hotel in Moscow and Tigran LaVon which
Petrosyan goes for efore we have E 5
sorry about that
nice to have three nights the c6 and now
comes the Bishop to c4 now I know what
you are all interesting how much opening
theories do these guys know well it's
fair to say quite a lot
we have rush up to c5 and now comes b4
yes the Evans gambit quite an excellent
move but unfortunately again it was not
played in this game so instead d3 the
joker pianissimo Knight to f6
we have Bishop to g5 and now h6 but h4
and here there are a few standard moves
in this position d6 is played here
castles is placed here and also g5 is a
well-known move here and with these
three moves there are over
over 350 games in the database but here
we have a six by Marty Rossum uh new
ones in the in the opening of this
position which of course should serve as
a surprise and there are only three
games in the database that that ever
reached this a sex move in this position
I'll move six so a four by preventing b5
with these six by black and not c3 are
preparing some expansion on the Queen
side also d4 will be an idea taking away
these two squares from last night Bush
of 287 not allowing before or d4 to come
with an attack on the bishop
we have castles by white and now comes
to Queen to e7 Knight B to d2 white
continues developing now comes g5 Bishop
to g3 and now Knight to d7 this Knight
now wants to come to f6 to f8 to g6 and
from there perhaps to f4 or h4 depending
on what what wife will play or or just
from g6 to support to the advancement of
the black king Saipan Bishop to d5 with
h5 by black and now comes h4 of course
you don't want to allow black to push h4
so we have h4 by white and now g4 and
now Knights the e1 Knight to g5 seems
like an interesting movie are already
threatening on f7 but after Knight
defense there's no good way to get this
Knights to safety whatever next move you
play doesn't really matter just f6 and
the knight is lost
so after g4 we have nice to be won and
now comes Knight to a fate as planned
the knight is now coming to g6 we have D
formed by white and now Knight to g6
pressuring the h4 pawn and now comes
Knight to c4 and here you could go
perhaps for capturing the h4 pawn but
then Whitehead plant if Knight captures
here it's okay you grab the pond but you
will have to waste a tempo with moving
the night and then only then you can
advance your pawns but then you get a
bunch of captures B captures and now D
captures on e5 and your King is still in
the center it's not not all that clear
whether you want to start opening up
positions like this so for example d5 of
course
white and black people not want to open
this nice to a5 threatening to capture
on c6 and black didn't really gain all
that much by this so it's it's playable
but if you haven't prepared it not not
definitely not going for it in the final
round of this very strong tournament so
it captures on d4 was played and now
comes Knight to d3 and here white or
white is offering the second point here
for example if pawn captures then the
idea is 'if I've again blacks Kings
stuck in the center you have white wants
to open up the position as soon as
possible so let's say D captures Knight
captures on e5 Knight G captures on e5
Knight captures Knight characters and
now after Bishop captures your rupees
under attack and if you move it some
roopd one ideas would become possible so
let's say castles but now after Bishop
captures on c3 it's it's a playable
position but white super ships are just
just do scary
so after Knight to d3 we have Knight CT
5 blocking thief the pawn and also
threatening to capture on c4
we have CT after Sunday for Knight
captures and c4 now Bishop captures on
c4 Bishop captures on d4 now and now
comes Knight to f4 and c5 so what's what
do we have here white can either choose
to sir about that position this Knight
very nicely on d5 d5 is an excellent
thought was for whites night and it will
not be all that easy to dislodge a
knight from there it comes with an
attack on the Queen but later black
could go Bishop e6 and 97 and and trade
off that night but here
Petrosyan goes for a different idea he
goes Knight captures on g6 we have F
captures on g6 yes you've busted open
the black King side but it's hard to say
if if it is okay to do this and here b4
is played of course now you cannot
capture here as the default bishop is
hanging and also there's quite a lot of
poison to the position if black decides
to play Bishop captures on a1 then after
Queen captures you were attacking the
rook and well we always return to this
the black King is still stuck in the
center of the board
example if Ruka fate you have to protect
the rook then comes Luke to d1 now
threatening Bishop captures on d6 and it
will not be all that easy to defend if
rock f6 and then comes he five and after
D captures Bishop captures let's say you
move rook to c6 then comes the B captors
on c5 with the threat of Bishop to d6
and then after the bishop moves Queen to
h8 is coming and it will not be possible
to defend here
you cannot capture the pawn bishop here
wins the rook if you capture with the
Queen that doesn't really help you white
will just move the bishop and even give
up some material for this Queen to h8
check and the black doesn't have a good
defense here let's say captures Queen h8
king of seven mushroom to h6 now and now
black is just getting checkmated Queen
c5 Queen g7 check King e8 you could go
Queen g8 check King 37 and now Bishop f8
check just wins the game if you go to
King to have sex a white will have to
play a few more moves but you can also
go here and allow white to this very
nice checkmate as all the squares around
the black king or covered so before a
lot of poison to the position black
doesn't go for but captures rather
Bishop to e6
you know development also matters we
have B captures on c5 d captures on c5
and Bishop captures on e6 Queen captures
and now comes Luke to be one with ideas
of capturing and b7 so b6 the Queen is
guarding the pawn from me sex with Queen
to b3 now offering a queen trade and
also pressuring the B sex pawn but now C
for avoiding the Queen trade and also
the bishop is guarding in the pawn here
now and here we have Queen to b4 Quintus
e2 was better here to keep out you know
for for the White King but after a Queen
to b4 we have Bishop to c5 attacking
whites Queen Queen to c3 and now comes
castles so there's quite a lot of
pressure against the White King here but
while the White King is a bit more safe
as you can see white managed to create a
blockade here with the bishop and the d
h4 pawn against all of this all all of
the points on the King side but here
rook F the c1 is played threatening to
capture on c4
and now comes Luke 88 now with the idea
of course if you capture the pawn then
you see what black had in mind of course
you do it's rook to d1 check now if you
capture then you lose the Queen the
Queen will no longer be protected and if
King h2 then just Queen captures and
after Luke captures euro can see one is
undefended unbe one is undefended so it
would be down a whole rook
so after rook a to d8 we have looked the
c2 and then out comes Luke to d4
defending the c4 pawn but also
pressuring the e4 pawn we have rook to
e1 defending and now comes b5 a captures
a captures and now Queen to a5
preventing before as the best one c5 is
unguarded but black just goes Queen to
c6
now b4 is definitely coming we have rook
to d1 and now before and here if white
just wait and does nothing then he will
simply be overwhelmed so here Y decides
to give up a look for a bishop and the
pawn with rook captures Bishop captures
and Queen captures so here a black is up
the exchange he's also up a pawn and
it's a very strong pass C pawn so let's
see how the game went from here first
the Queen captures on e4 eliminating
that point soon only now black is up an
extra pawn rook to a2 going up to a 7
perhaps some checkmating ideas will you
know present themselves for example it's
not impossible to imagine if the Queen
can get to c7 look here it will be very
hard to prevent checkmate so black has
to be very careful about this first
Queen to e6 defending the pawn but also
keeping an eye on this diagonal we have
King 2h to first and now rook to d7 not
allowing this rook lifts we have looked
the c2 now preventing the the pushing of
the C pawn rook the c8 the also
defending the pawn and now we have Queen
to c3 blockading the pawn we have looked
the d3 forcing the Queen to move Queen
to a5 and now comes Luke to d1 and here
black has some ideas of going Queen to
e1 which would offer a queen trade but
also threatened checkmate here so white
goes Queen to g5 now there's no time
go for any checkmating ideas here
because the g6 pawn is hanging so black
goes c3 improves the position just
pushes that pass pawn even further we
have Queen to h6 by white with ideas the
White House that the rook will be kicked
from there so rook to e 2 followed by
Bishop to e5 are some hopes that white
has of delivering still delivering
checkmate we have Queen to a5 not
attacking the rook now comes look to e2
and now c2 and now threats are c1 you
know just bring another Queen into the
game so white played Bishop to e5 and
this is the really position that makes
this game what it is it's quite quite a
wonderful position white is threatening
checkmate on g7 and black of course is
not interested in that black wants to
finish the game so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
winning move for black I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
Tigran Petrosian
and for those if you just want to enjoy
the show if you found King if you found
g3 checked this also works so we're just
gonna show this line after g3 check F
captures now you play rook to h1 check
King has the capture because there's
nowhere to go King captures and now you
bring a queen into the game with check
now the Queen has to capture as you've
connected to check with an attack on the
Queen Queen captures rook captures and
now after King moves you're just up up a
queen I mean a queen for a bishop a
completely winning game you're just
gonna finish this game with a nice
checkmate but this was not played in the
game in the game Marty Rosen had a
different idea one I prefer that the g3
check its rook to h1 immediately and
here white doesn't want to capture the
rook because well again upon just want
to see one here
Petrosyan played King to g3 and this is
why I enjoyed this line more again if
you were you know able to do it again
pause the video here and try to find the
next continuation for black it is the
only line that works that actually wins
for black so I'll give you a couple of
seconds to do that as well again white
is threatening
checkmate but like I said for those of
you who were able to do it you have just
defeated Tigran Petrosian and for those
who just wanna enjoy a short look to h3
a wonderful idea and it was after this
move that didn't live on which Petrosyan
resigned to the game there is only one
move you have to capture the rook with
the pawn and that means you are no
longer defending the f3 pawn and your
pawn is the only thing protecting you
from this Queen here so if pawn captures
which is the only move we have to be
check you have to move Queen captures on
h3 check now the King has to move and
now finally you get c1 Queen which comes
with check Queen captures and after
captures rook rook e1 rook will capture
to deliver checkmate so a wonderful idea
just you know congratulations to
everyone who found the g3 but also to
everyone who found rook to h1 both of
the ideas are just wonderful now a
wonderful victory for her hike
Martirosyan and he's the only player at
the moment that I was recording this
video with seven other nine points so I
don't know if he is the winner of the
arrow flood open 2019 I'm gonna have to
check after I finish the video but you
know I will inform you in the
description below so do check it out
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
branford 'dearest for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully what's a more interesting
content we took a little break from the
capablanca saga but we are continuing
with that for more games to go in the 9
to 14 tournament of some Peterburg and
then we'll see where we're gonna go for
there from there i still haven't decided
so thank you all and I will see you soon